Give a little bit Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Give a little bit of my love to me.
Nee, wir müssen was anderes singen.
Das ist Quatsch, wir können nicht jetzt irgendwelche Coca-Cola-Songs singen.
Das ist urheberrechtlich Quatsch.
Also einen Pepsi-Song singen.
Ich fand, Single Ladies haben wir sehr gut gemacht, aber haben wir Zeit schon, aber wir haben sonst keine Songs.
Single Ladies, single ladies, single ladies, single ladies, aber dann denken die Leute, was, schon wieder Folge acht, habe ich mich da geirrt? Habe ich mich wohl verklickt? Habe ich mich verklickt, was ist das denn? Nein, das ist die Folge, das ist die Folge siebzehn, oder? Dumm, didim, dim, didim, didim, didim, didim, didim, didim, la la la la la.
Ne, wir machen heute etwas Barockes. Die Folge 17, oder?
Nee, wir machen heute mal was Barockes.
Ich weiss nicht, was Barockes ist. Oder wir machen mal Flipglas. Bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super, Super,, dass ich für die richtige Anmoderation entschieden habe. Dankeschön. Das war die lustigere, du lernst mittlerweile wirklich gut dazu. Danke, danke, danke, danke. Glaubst du nicht, dass die Leute uns während dem Grillen hören? Ich glaube, die Leute hören uns vorrangig beim Grillen und beim Sex tatsächlich, glaube ich. Ich glaube, sie hören uns auf dem, wenn es ihnen ganz schlecht geht, wenn sie weinen, zum Beispiel in Situationen, wo sie gerade gefeuert werden, wo ein Verwandter gestorben ist, enger, dann hören die uns, glaube wieder hochzukommen. Im Flugzeug vielleicht gestorben. Ja, genau. Man hört das, glaube ich, auch im Flugzeug. Man hat noch ein bisschen Wasser im Hals, man ist noch ein bisschen frostlich. Ja, weil man uns hört, weiß man nämlich, da sind noch Menschen, denen geht es noch beschissener. Obwohl dies auch vielleicht, also denen geht es nicht gut. Oder so als Stimmungsmusik, wenn man ein paar Freunde da hat, irgendwie zum Essen, dann macht man einfach, statt Musik macht man einfach mal einen schönen Podcast an. Alle Leute, die Leute wollen Single Ladies hören, wollen tanzen, und dann hat einer die grandiosste Idee, nein, wir machen heute mal was anderes, wir hören mal das Podcast-Ufo und alle sind super down der Richte. Aber hat das schon mal jemand gemacht? Ich stelle mir immer so, also ich bin ja ein großer Freund von unangenehmen Situationen und frage mich oft in Situationen, in denen ich bin, was ist das Unangenehmste, was man jetzt machen könnte? Irgend zum Beispiel eine Frau eingeladen, und man möchte die Stimmung so ein bisschen auf einem anderen Level machen und macht deswegen einfach einen Podcast an. Hey, hast du was zugegen, wenn ich kurz einen Podcast anmache? Nee. Am besten auch so einen B.O.B. Podcast. Ein B.O.B., zweieinhalbstündiger Podcast, wo im Detail die DPS-Spitzen der neuen Schurken-Patch-Einstellungen diskutiert werden. Einfach, um die Stimmung bisschen zu machen. Oder was ich mir auch dachte, ich habe dir ja auch erzählt von dem Album von Lena Marlandroth, wo nicht nur die zwölf Songs raus sind, sondern noch zwölf weitere Songs, wo immer Lena Marlandroth interviewt wird, wie sie die Songs geschrieben hat. Und wenn man einfach die anmacht, weißt du, die zwölf, wo einfach Lena Marlandroth interviewt sind. Aber aus Versehen, aus Versehen, man rechnet hier, ich wollte dir das Album zeigen, super geile Songs und dann kommt dazwischen peinlicherweise diese Scheiß. Oder ich meine, du kennst es ja höchstwahrscheinlich, man überlegt sich eine coole Playlist, wenn es mal wieder erotischer wird und wenn man dann gerade dabei ist und die Playlist sich nicht so ganz verhält, wie man es möchte und dann irgendwelche komischen Songs ankommen. Man hat den Shuffle-Modus angelassen, dann kommt der Safety-Dance plötzlich, was will man da machen? Oder Der Hobbit, das Hör Hörbuch. So was ist dann einfach ein bisschen unangenehm. Und die Frage ist dann, hört man dann auf und sagt, du, lass mich nochmal ganz kurz. Aber das ist eine schwierige Situation. Das sind so die Tücken des Menschenlebens. Live-Alben sind auch meistens nicht gut. Vor allem die, wo dann so zwischendurch so fünf Minuten. So Olli Schulz, wo Anekdoten erzählen dazwischen ist. Ja genau, vor allem so fünf Minuten Anmoderation, wo einfach getrunken wird und niemand was sagt, man hört nur so ein paar spitze Schreie und so ein Wuuuu. Ja genau, die Band baut auf oder sowas. Ja genau, das ist nicht so geil. Oder halt, ich glaube Soundtracks sind auch ein bisschen irreführend, irgendwie so der Jurassic Park Soundtrack, glaube ich, kommt auch ein bisschen komisch. Könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass es ein bisschen uncool kommt. Für so ein Rollenspiel bestimmt total geil. Aber dann machen wir was anderes. Ein Dinosaurier-Rollenspiel, ja, klar. Also ich finde, die hören uns nicht beim Grillen. Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen beim Grillen so ein bisschen. Aber es ist natürlich auch schwer, einen Podcast zu finden, der die ganzen Geschmack trifft. Tante Elsa ist da, die kleine Miriam ist da, Tina ist endlich mal wieder gekommen aus Hongkong, die studierte in Hongkong,, ist jetzt wieder da und man will was finden, was allgemeinverträglich ist. Deswegen macht doch ihr einfach mal beim nächsten Grillfest einfach ungefragt das Podcast-UFO an und zählt bitte mit, wie lange es dauert, bis die erste Person sich beschwert oder die Musik ändert. Kommentarlos die Situation verlässt. Ja, macht das einfach mal. Waren wir gerade, habe ich das Redaktion verstanden, wir haben gerade Tipps gegeben für einen natürlichen Umgang, oder wir haben Leuten erzählt, was unangenehm ist in Alltagssituationen, dass wir uns schon in der Position sehen, Leuten zu sagen, was unangenehm ist, ist auch so ein sehr gut eigentlich. Ja, aber da kennen wir uns halt aus, das ist genau unser Niveau. Das ist ein Statement. Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, wenn man irgendwie in einer Situation mit einer Person ist, die einem nicht so ganz geheuer ist, dann einfach in die Unangenehmigkeit hineinziehen, weil da hat man auf jeden Fall den Trumpf in der Hand. Da kennt man sich aus. Da fühlen wir uns zu Hause. Da kommt so ein heimliches Gefühl, ach, hier sind wir zu Hause, hier weiß ich, wie ich wieder rauskomme. Du, sobald eine Frau zu mir sagt, ist das Senf auf deiner Hose, bin ich zu Hause, ja, da kann gar nichts mehr schiefgehen, da bin ich in meiner Comfortzone, da bin ich einfach angekommen. Da macht dich so ein wohliges Grinsen auf deinem Gesicht breit. Ach, endlich sind wir da, wo ich das ganze Gespräch hinführen wollte. Du machst ja manchmal extra Senf irgendwie auf die Hose, damit du in das Gefühl herkommst, ne? Ja, genau, absolut. Oder machst du ein bisschen so atmosphärische Sphärenklänge an im Wohnzimmer, so wenn jemand zu Besuch ist,, einfach so ganz leise, so in den Boxen, an den Ecken, auch an den Decken. Ich will ja immer, ich fände es ja gut, wenn man so Boxen wie in Kaufhäusern hat, so an den Decken, an die man noch nicht rankommt, die man nicht kontrollieren kann, wo ständig irgendwelche Sachen laufen, die andere Leute einstellen, wo man keinen Einfluss drauf hat. Oder irgendwie dann so sanfter Regen und so Regenwald und so. Wahlgesänge. Ja, aber das auch nicht so auftrinlich ist, dass Leute sagen, sag mal, geht's noch, sondern es einfach so hinnehmen müssen. Und es ist einfach fünf Minuten merken. Haben wir laufen da eigentlich, haben wir gerade Gorillas gehört im Hintergrund? Was ist das? Ich habe mal die Situation gehabt, ich bin, ich habe Leute aus der Uni zum ersten Mal irgendwie irgendwo hingebracht mit dem Auto. Ich musste fahren und ich kannte die noch nicht so lange, deswegen wollte ich besonders cool wirken. Und ich dachte, du musst heute besonders cool fahren, du musst auch mit einer Hand am Lenkrad immer nur so ganz cool fahren. Genau, der rechte Arm so über den Beifahrersitz. Genau, genau, richtig, das war der Plan, komm besonders cool weg, mach nicht aus Versehen den Scheibenwischer an, hub Leute an, hub Leute an, sofort, wenn nicht sofort bei Grün eine Millisekunde danach nicht gefahren sind, sofort hupen, die ganzen coolen Sachen machen.
Das erste, wir steigen ein ins Auto und es lief, das Radio war sehr laut aufgedreht und es lief eine CD, so eine Musical-CD. Es war sehr laut, ein Musical aufgedreht und man hörte nur so, mitten im Song plötzlich so ein End, kennt man diese typischen Musical-Enden, wo alle so Arme hoch machen, fertig und es war unfassbar laut, es war unfassbar peinlich, alle haben gelacht und man weiss auch nicht, wie man aus dieser Saison wieder rauskommen soll. Ich glaube, das einzige, was noch unangenehmer wäre, wäre so eine Selbstmotivations-Zene, wie man selber aufgenommen hat, wie Stefan, du kannst das, Stefan, du bist nicht so gross, Stefan, du siehst nicht scheiße aus, heute ist ein Tag. Stefan, du kannst deine Capcom-Militonen wegbringen, cool wegbringen, du kommst dabei cool rüber.
Genau, und du kannst Anja ansprechen, ist es okay, du bist mutig und so. Anja verdreht die Augen. So, Anja ist es nur für so ein Uni-Projekt. Ja, das war echt maximal unangenehm, aber das sind die Situationen, wo man sich halt zu Hause fühlt, wenn man. Habe ich tatsächlich manchmal gemacht. Ich hatte mal so eine kreative Phase, wo ich irgendwie dann, du kennst ja so dieses Künstler-Dasein, dass man immer einen Notizblock dabei hat, so dieses, wenn ich mal eine Idee habe, wenn mich die Muse küsst, dann schreibe ich das nieder und ich habe das einfach direkt auf den nächsten Level gehoben und habe dann immer so Sprachaufnahmen gemacht von mir, halt wie so ein richtiger Drehbuchautor, der dann irgendwie macht und dann hatte ich die immer in meiner Library und manchmal tatsächlich, wenn wenn Leute da waren, war es immer im Zufälligmodus und es war immer so ein bisschen russisch Roulette, so ein bisschen Scheiße, wenn das jetzt kommt, bin ich komplett am Arsch. Florian, du schwitzt schon wieder, ja, es ist kurz vor Ende des Songs, es ist kurz vor Ende des Songs, alle drei Minuten habe ich eine Panikattack. 24. April 2008, die Geschichte von Werwölfen, die auf dem Mond landen. Was würde passieren, wie würden sie sich ... Die Zugfährt an mir vorbei. Weit nicht mehr. Idee für Kurzgeschenk, die Lampe ist angegangen, ich mache sie wieder aus. Genau, ja. Ich habe in der Tat mal so, ich habe ja früher in einer Band gespielt, wir haben viele Songideen immer zwischendurch aufgenommen und einfach eingesungen. Und da hat man immer, man singt das nämlich nicht, also ich weiß nicht, ob es andere Leute da draußen gibt, die das auch so machen. Das Ding ist halt, man macht es nicht auf Deutsch oder man singt nicht auf Englisch, sondern man hat halt die Melodie im Kopf. Und man fällt einem halt nicht sofort einen Text darauf ein, der auf diese Melodie passt. Also singt man so eine Phantasiesprache, die man sich selber ausgedacht hat. Und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kann man auch, kann ich in dieser Phantasiesprache mit anderen Musikern reden, die das auch gleichzeitig machen. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das eine Sprache, die sich ergibt. Ich glaube, das ist eine universelle Sprache, ja. Das ist eine universelle Sprache der Musik. Die Ursprache des Menschen eigentlich. Ja, es ist aber unfassbar peinlich. Und irgendwann hat irgendwer auch mein Handy gefunden und hat das mal angemacht, es gibt nichts Peinliches. Es ist wirklich das Schlimmste. Es ist wie nackt mit ganz kleinem Penis über Schildergasse in Köln. Ich glaube, Musik ist da tatsächlich so ein Maximum. Auch so Melodien so ... Na, na, na, na, na, na, na. Aber warum ist vor jemandem Singen vor anderen Leuten viel, viel peinlicher oder viel, viel nervenaufreibender, als vor jemandem zu sprechen? Also es ist ja nicht viel anders. Es ist halt nur Wörter in eine Melodie gepackt. Aber viel anders ist er ja nicht, oder? Aber es ist maximal unangenehm. Trotzdem, wenn man das nicht immer macht, oder? Ja. Du singst ja auch vor anderen Menschen. Ich singe sehr, sehr gern vor anderen Menschen, ja, tatsächlich. Es ist aber tatsächlich immer, wenn ich singe, kurz bevor ich singe, denke ich mir, ich kann singen. Und drei Sekunden, nachdem ich angefangen zu singen, denke ich mir jedes Mal, sing nie wieder, nie wieder. Stell es auf deine, damit kannst du Leute nicht beeindrucken Liste. Aber ich mache jedes Mal den Fehler genau immer selber. ich denke immer, ich habe ein zu großes Selbstbewusstsein, was meine Gesangsfähigkeiten angeht, ich denke, ich könnte singen bis zu dem Moment, in dem ich anfange zu singen, das ist eine Katastrophe, das funktioniert. Man könnte es sich irgendwann mal merken, man könnte irgendwann mal sagen, hey, das ist, du hast es schon ein paar Mal probiert, lass es einfach, aber so reflektiert bist du nicht, oder? Du, wenn ich so handeln würde, könnte ich nie wieder einen Podcast aufnehmen. So, hat es ein bisschen gedauert, um an dem anzukommen, an der Pointe. Und dafür war sie super. Ja, wenn du jetzt die acht Minuten Stille rausschneiden würdest, würde ich dich drum bitten. Auf auf keinen Fall. Ich schreibe mir meine Pausen raus, wo ich nachdenke, damit ich besser wegkomme als du. Ich glaube, ich komme die Pointe ein bisschen besser raus. Stefan, was, ich meine, wie muss man sich die vorstellen? Ich habe das Gefühl, der Frühling ist da, du hast heute so ein bisschen im Park rumgetäult, ich bin ein bisschen gesund. Hier wurde immer mein Achselshirt angezogen, mein Muskelshirt, ohne Ärmel und ohne Hose aus Versehen, das war aber nicht geplant, rumgelaufen. Diese neue Halskette finde ich ganz schön, so dieses dicke schwarze Band mit dem Halbmond. Es ist eine Tattoo-Halskette. Es ist eine Tattoo-Halsk ist ein Hals-Tattoo und die werden sehr modern. Genau wie Latzhosen, habe ich mir sagen lassen. Ja, wirklich? Latzhosen und in der Kombination, beides zusammen ist supergeil, bist du sofort angesprochen. Leute, lachen dich an, glaube ich. Aber jetzt bist du wieder zu Hause angekommen, ich stelle mir vor, du sitzt in einem Massagesessel, trinkst eine schöne Tasse warmeren Red Bull, hast irgendwie das Telefonbuch von 2008 auf dem Schoss und blätterst einfach mal ein bisschen rum, geniesst den Abend. Wie muss man sich das bei dir vorstellen? Was ist da los? Es ist nicht das Telefonbuch von 2008, es ist der Duden von 2008 und ich suche, ich vergleiche den mit dem Duden von 2012. Was hat sich geändert? Da bist du hängen geblieben. Bis 2008 hast du es wirklich genäht, einfach die deutsche Sprache. Ich bin schon bei C. Ach was. Glaubst nicht. Es ist wahr. Es haben sich wahnsinnig viele Wörter geändert, viele sind dazugekommen, es ist toll, diesen Wandel der Zeit zuzuschauen. Das ist doch die beste Art. Steht eigentlich das Wort Duden im Duden? Oder ist das nur so ein Inception MP3? Wie gesagt, ich bin erst bei C, ich kann dir das erst nach D sagen. Weil Duden fängt mit D an, scheiß Idiot. Stimmt, aber wenn man das nicht weiß, wie soll man dann nachschlagen? Was machst du denn? Du bist wirklich so ein Frühlingsmensch, der sich auch direkt im Frühling anfängt zu verlieben, ne? Ja, absolut. Frühlingsstart, du bist verliebt. Direkt verliebt in die erste Person, die mal im Weg läuft, zack, bam, verliebt und dann geht's bergab. Das ist natürlich dann immer ein großes Problem. Der Person läufst du dann auch bis nach Hause, folgst du ihr einfach in irgendeiner Station, weiss nicht wo du bist, aber du folgst ihr einfach mal wild.
Ja, knallhart und ich versuche ein bisschen cooler zu werden, ich habe mich entschlossen, dieses Jahr ein bisschen cooler zu werden. Keine Musical-CDs. Nein, ich habe alle Musical-CDs weggeschmissen. Ich habe alles weggeworfen, die ganzen uncoolen Magazine habe ich weggeworfen, die ganzen Magazine mit Flirt-Tipps. Das ist, glaube ich, auch ein ganz cooles Ding. Erstes Date, man lädt eine Frau zu sich nach Hause an und hat auf dem Rechner noch irgendwie so ein Wie spreche ich Frauen an? Fünf Tipps YouTube-Video offen oder irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung. Finde ich auch schön, aber da in die Richtung
will ich gehen. Ich will cooler werden, ich will mich
ein bisschen emanzipieren, ich will Drogen nehmen,
ich will Alkohol trinken, ich will richtig cool werden.
Das Nächste, was ich tatsächlich
an Drogen in meinem Haus habe, sind diese
von den In-Ear-Kopfhörern, diese
Gummiaufsätze, die so ein bisschen aussehen wie Pilze.
So ein bisschen. Das ist das
Drogenähnlichste, was ich konsumiert habe in meinem Leben. Das soll sich ändern, ich muss cooler werden.
Ich glaube, mein Müll ist dem, was einer Droge am nächsten kommt, glaube ich, im ganzen Block, im ganzen Block. Es ist wirklich enorm, was ich da heranzüchte, jede Woche aufs Neue. Natürlich bringe ich den Müll maximal wenig raus, aber man kann auch sagen, minimal, hätte man auch sagen können, aber es wäre mir zu einfach gewesen.
Und das ist wirklich, was da heran können, aber es wäre mir zu einfach gewesen.
Und das ist wirklich, was da heranwächst immer und für tolle Farben. Also der Schimmel, der ist mittlerweile nicht mehr nur hell, sondern mittlerweile auch grün mal blau. Und ich bin mal ganz gespannt, mache ich den Müll auf, ist eine neue Farbe da, was, wenn ich da jetzt ganz doll riechen werde, was würde passieren, würde ich umkippen? Ich habe einen ganz besonderen Platz in meinem Herzen reserviert für Schimmel in Flüssigkeiten. Das ist, finde ich, nochmal was ganz was Feines. Das ist so toll, nur die Formen, vor allem wenn man geil so Multivitaminsaft in der Sonne stehen lässt, irgendwie am Fenster und dann tut vielleicht eine Woche lang die Sonne drauf, diese Formen, die sich dann bilden. Ja, vor allem, ich frage mich immer, wo kommt das her? Diese Kulturen, das sind so kleine Kulturen. Ja, aber ich meine, ich frage mich immer, wo kommt das her? Also ich meine, angenommen, du siehst jetzt ein Haus auf der Erde, dann kannst du dir denken, okay, die Wesen, die das gebaut haben, haben Ressourcen aus der Erde genommen und haben daraus ein Haus gebaut. Aber wenn du jetzt ein schwimmendes Haus auf dem Wasser sehen würdest, würdest du dir denken, hm, wie funktioniert das denn? Wie kommt das denn daher? So denke ich mir bei Schimmeln immer auch, wo kommt dieses Material her? Also der Schimmelpilz muss sich ja auf irgendwas absetzen und dann da irgendwie harvisten, so ernten, um zu wachsen. Aber das geht ja auf dem Wasser nicht. Es ist Wurstwasser. Ganz am Anfang war die Erde ja nur ein Wasserball. Nein. Und guck, guck, was wir jetzt alles haben. Ist letztendlich nicht alles Schimmel, auch gehärteter Schimmel irgendwo? Letztendlich bist du ein Haufen wandelnder Schimmel mit Gitarre manchmal. Wäre es nicht sau lustig, so bei der Polizeikontrolle, wenn der Polizist fragt, haben sie was getrunken, man so ganz beschämt sagt, zwei Gläser Wurstwasser. Tut mir leid jetzt, man muss ja ehrlich sein, wenn ein Polizist mit dir redet, musst du ehrlich sein, egal was du hast und du musst die grössten Peinlichkeiten zugeben. Ein Arbeitskollege ist neulich ein bisschen betrunken, glaube ich mit 0,5 Promille gefahren, hat dann leider einen Unfall gebaut, hat selber, da fing dann die Problemkette an, selber die Polizei gerufen und dann kam irgendwann die Frage auf. Er hat aus Versehen die Feuerwehr gerufen, weil er komplett betrunken war. Aus kam aus Versehen die Frage auf, haben Sie denn was getrunken? Und er sagt ja. Man merkt das ja auch nicht an, wenn er hat, 0,5 ist ja nicht viel, also du solltest nicht mehr fahren, niemand sollte mehr, also liebe Podcast-Ufohörer, du solltest nicht mehr fahren dann, aber man sollte dann auch vielleicht nicht mehr diese Frage beantworten einfach. Stimmt, genau, ich gebe das mal ab an meinen Anwalt, ab jetzt redet nicht mehr ich. Eigentlich sollte man nicht mehr für sich selbst reden, wenn man betrunken ist. Ich kann diese Frage nicht beantworten einfach. Also man kann ja einfach, kann man dann einfach rücken. Ich gebe das mal ab an meinen Anwalt, aber jetzt redet nicht mehr ich. Eigentlich sollte man nicht mehr für sich selbst reden, wenn man kommt. Ich möchte diese Frage nicht beantworten, wegrennen. Nehme diese Frage nicht an. Tipp ins Polizeiauto setzen und wegrennen. So fangen nämlich die meisten coolen Filme an. Aber hat man wirklich dieses Recht, die Aussage zu verweigern, oder ist das nur so ein Hollywood-Ding? Ja, vor allem, als ob die Polizei da nichts machen würde. Wenn man die Frage nicht beantwortet, hat man offensichtlich was getrunken. Ja, eben, vor allem, ich meine, was soll das denn heißen, das Recht zu schweigen? Ja, wow, tolles Recht, was soll dir das denn bringen? Das ist genau so bescheuert wie die Amerikaner, die, weil sie ja nicht auf offener Strasse Alkohol trinken dürfen, diese braunen Plastiktüten, diese braunen Papiertüten haben, um was zu trinken. You don't fool anyone. Was ist da wohl drin? Trinkst du da Multivitaminsaft?
Wurstwasser vielleicht, dafür schämt man sich auch gerne.
Ja, trinkst du damit, genau, Spargelwasser.
Wurstwasser ist viel berühmter als zum Beispiel Gurkenwasser.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich finde, Gurkenwasser ist immer so eine Faszination, so Cornichons, so Gewürzgürkchen, die man dann hat.
Da bleibt dann immer so, da ist ganz viel Kraut. Wie heißt das im Englischen? Pickischen? Oh, da fällt mir tatsächlich was ein, aber ich glaube, das verschiebe ich später. Da ist dann immer so Kraut drin und so Monokulturen und ich glaube, da liegt eine ganze Welt drin in dieser Lake von diesen Gewürzgurken, da könnte man wahrscheinlich, wenn man das stehen lässt, irgendwie wird dann irgendwie die Renaissance geht los und dann so Mittelalter Musik kommt dann da raus wie bei den Simpsons. Eine der besten Folgen, die ich jemals fand. Also die Vorstellung, so eine eigene kleine Welt zu haben, so eine Monokultur, wo dann auch wirklich winzig kleine Menschen leben, fand ich immer super gut. Diese Theorie hatte ich relativ früh in meinem Leben, fing ich an zu glauben, als ich gelernt habe, dass in Atomen bewegen sich ja auch, also der Atomkern ist ja alles in Bewegung, also die kleinsten Teile sind ja dann in Bewegung, da drehen sich ja Dinge um, also Elektronen drehen sich um den Atomkern und so weiter. Ja, und du dachtest, es wäre wieder ein Sonnensystem, oder was? Ja, genau, sowas, also das ist natürlich sehr vereinfacht. Tolle, originelle Idee. Ne, sehr vereinfacht, ja, wieso denn nicht? Warum machst du denn nicht die Idee, ich war 15 oder so? Du hattest die Idee nicht mit 15. Ich hatte die letzte Woche. Du hattest nicht die, mit 15 hattest du nicht die Idee, dass das kleinste System genauso aufgebaut ist wie das grösste System. Die Idee hattest du nicht mit 15, nein, hattest du nicht die Idee. Ich schwöre, ich hätte die Fläche. Nein, hattest du nicht die Idee. Okay, alles klar, alles klar, sorry, du hast recht. Du hast jetzt nicht mehr nur einen einzigen Podcast, du hast jetzt auch einen anderen Podcast, denn dein anderes Podcast-Projekt ist wieder gestartet. Ich möchte ein bisschen Werbung machen, weil du nicht rechtst, weil du zu bescheiden bist. Nein, du bist ein bescheidener Typ und das finde ich auch okay. Ich wollte gleich ein bisschen Feedback geben, ich wollte gleich ein bisschen Feedback geben. Und es ist richtig toll, allerdings wollte ich es heute anhören auf dem Weg in die Stadt, ich bin mit der U-Bahn gefahren und wollte es auf meinem iPod anhören. Ist ja nicht über iTunes rundherladbar, oder warum auch, sondern bei Soundcloud. Und bei Soundcloud ist es tatsächlich so, du kannst es dir mobil anhören, aber sobald du dann wieder ins Hauptmenü wächst, der Bildschirm ausgeht, hört es einfach auf. Das heißt, ich habe diese fucking Folge unter Qualen angehört, nämlich in der U-Bahn stand wie der letzte Trottel von 2007, der sein iPhone ständig in der Hand hält und irgendwie ständig irgendwie irgendwie draufdappt, nicht ausgeht. Ich habe mich gefühlt wie der letzte Depp, also da möchte ich schon mal ganz, ganz schlechtes Feedback geben, dass das, unabhängig vom Inhalt, der natürlich eine Katastrophe war, da soll ich drüber reden, aber vom Technischen her, also furchtbar, möchte ich nichts mehr mit zu tun haben. Man muss vor allem auch dazu sagen, ich habe Soundcloud noch nie ganz verstanden. Also irgendwann kommt man auch manchmal auf so Seiten, wo dann diese Waveform zu sehen ist,
was ich auch schon fragwürdig finde, aber eigentlich ganz cool,
und dann zwischendurch sind dann so Bilder zu sehen, wo Leute was dazu sagen.
Also könnte man dann auf Stellen, man kann auf Stellen kommentieren direkt.
Ja, das finde ich tatsächlich geil.
Das ist geil dann.
Wenn du den Podcast gerade anhörst bei Minute zwanzig und du schreibst einen Kommentar,
dann wird auch die Zeit, an der du das schreibst, mitgespeichert.
Das ist cool. Und wenn du den folgst, das finde ich richtig cool. Und ich finde, so etwas soll es auch bei YouTube geben. Oder bei iTunes. Kennst du, bei YouTube-Kommentaren ist es ja oft so, beste Stelle 21, 30 und ich muss mir das nochmal anschauen, was das für eine Stelle war. Egal was, auch wenn ich mir ein Video komplett anschaue und da sagt jemand, hey, wie lustig denn, Minute 0,30, ich muss es nochmal anschauen. Es geht nicht anders. Wenn das bei YouTube bei so einem Riesenhit dann und jeder, was so 20 Millionen Klicks hat und jeder kann seine Meinung zu jeder Stelle auch noch zugeben, dann sieht man irgendwann kein Bild mehr, man sieht einfach nur Kommentare, alles ist voll. Ja, das stimmt natürlich, das müssen wir natürlich, wir können dann wieder ein Voting-System einreichen, dass nur die die besten 10% oder so angezeigt werden, egal. Haben sich bestimmt schon klügerer Menschen über Gedanken gemacht, aber tatsächlich Das ist eine Scheisseinstellung. Nein, das ist eine gute Einstellung. Wenn jeder sagt, da hat sich jemand ein klügeres Gedanken zu gemacht, dann kommt man es ausserweit nicht. Schuster bleibt bei deinen Leisten, ich argumentiere nur noch mit Sprichwörtern, Schuster bleibt bei deinen Leisten. Ja, ich sag mal kurz, Sauer macht lustig, in der Hinsicht, dass ich sagen möchte, diese Universumstheorie, dass das kein Sau das Grösste ist, habe ich lange, lange überlegt, ob es vielleicht eine gute Idee ist von mir und habe dann auch irgendwann angefangen, das zu googeln. Man weiß aber, ich wusste nicht, wie ich das googeln soll. Sind Atome Universen? Atome ist gleich Universum? Fragezeichen. Ja, genau. Und dann habe ich herausgefunden, dass doch jemand tatsächlich schon viel schlauer war als ich. Das ist jetzt ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber es gibt bestimmt auch Dinge, die dir einfallen und die nicht schon jemand hat, sondern du kannst da auch ein bisschen Innovationsgeist mal zeigen, an den Tag legen und mal ein bisschen Ideen weiterverfolgen. Ja, aber nicht in Physik, nicht in einem Fachgebiet, das es schon gibt. Wir können gerne über DocTV so lange philosophieren, wie du willst, da kommen neue Ideen bei raus, weil damit hat sich einfach noch keine Sau oder Gamecours. Apropos, hey, neue Ideen, supergeil, ich bin ein riesen Fan davon, ich muss kurz Werbung machen dafür. Kennst du von, hast du von GoButler gehört? Nein. Das ist ein Dienst, der macht alles für dich. Du musst da deine E-Mail-Adresse eintragen, dann kriegst du einen Code und eine Nummer. Und jeder hat quasi eine Handynummer, der immer schreiben kann, der muss dann den Code schicken, dann bist du freigeschaltet. Dann kannst du dem jeden Auftrag der Welt, jedes, alles, kleinste Problem, alles darf nur nicht illegal sein, das ist die einzige Einschränkung, dann kannst du dem alles auftragen, zum Beispiel, bring bitte meine Pfannflaschen weg, dann kommt jemand vorbei und bring deine Pfannflaschen weg, ich hätte gerne eine Pizza um bis 18 Uhr, dann kommt eine Pizza bis 18 Uhr und alles ist kostenlos, nur die Dinge, die Geld kosten, da berechnen die halt so einen kleinen Aufschlag, zum Beispiel, buch mir einen Flug, so, und dann buchen die das, aber dann berechnen die dann einen kleinen Aufschlag, und so, da finanzieren sie sich drüber. Aber eine geile Idee eigentlich, du kannst alles machen, die können alles für dich machen. Wollen wir uns nicht mal sponsern lassen von solchen Apps eigentlich? Ich meine, jetzt mal ohne Witz, ich meine, es gibt genug Podcasts, die das machen. Ich finde, du machst so gut Werbung, ich finde, du hast das gerade so toll erzählt. Für mich ist es fast ein bisschen zu einfach zu bedienen und zu innovativ und zu ... Es ist sehr minimalistisch. Ja, aber ich bin immer ein bisschen skeptisch für Dinge, die zu benutzerfreundlich sind. Ich bin per se gegen Benutzerfreundlichkeit. Ich habe zum Beispiel heute meinen Job outgesourced. Ich saß heute im Redaktionsraum. Zehn Gangs bis sechzehn Uhr. Ja, habe ich original hingeschickt.
Es kam zwar relativ viel Scheiße zurück, also die geben sich dann keine Mühe, wenn die merken, dass man Dinge verlangt, die nicht so weit nachgehen können. Aber die gehen dem auch nach. Glaubst du, dass Humor das einzige ist, was Maschinen niemals können werden? Der erste Beruf, der ersetzt wird für komplette Maschinen, sind Gag-Autor. Aber wie gut das wäre, oder, wenn man sich einfach so Gags ständig aus der Dose holen könnte. Total geil. Ein bisschen wie Gag-Flat-Rate. Da bin ich mir auch nicht sicher, ob da Menschen dran sitzen oder ob das nicht so ein paar Maschinen sind, die einfach random Wörter aneinandersetzen. Naja, der Gedanke zählt. Ist Humor messbar? Nein. Also, ich glaube, das war eine dumme Frage, die du da gestellt hast.
Naja.
Wollen wir mal kurz zu den Themen gehen, die wir heute eigentlich...
Ja, ich wollte tatsächlich gerade zu den Themen überleiten.
Oder wolltest du komplett einfach die Themen ignorieren?
Nein, ich wollte gerade mit der Gedanke zählt
wollte ich Thema überleiten.
Oh, sehr gut. Heute ist unser
Thema... Ja, genau,
Sushi ist heute unser Thema. Wir reden heute mal über die wahrscheinlich beliebteste fernöstliche Delikatesse, die es gibt, Sushi.
Und Magnete, komischerweise sind wir wieder bei einem Leben in Landen.
Und Magnete kommt tatsächlich immer wieder zurück. Ne, heute geht es ums Schenken, die schönste Sache der Welt, anderen Leuten Dinge schenken, selbst Sachen geschenkt bekommen.
Und ich reibe mich ja immer an den Begriff, der Gedanke zählt. Weil eigentlich nicht. Natürlich schon. Der Gedanke zählt. Ist das jetzt Kant oder der andere? Der Gedanke zählt ist Kant. Der hat damit gesagt, dass das Ergebnis völlig irrelevant ist, wichtig ist nur, dass du pflichtmäßig handelst. Das ist also, bist du ein Kant. Ich bin ein Kant-Kritiker in dem Moment, weil ich meine, das ist ein bisschen so wie ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, aber mein Vater, ich bin immer mit meinem Vater Auto gefahren und dann ging immer so der Mythos rum, ja, der Tacho zeigt immer ein bisschen schneller an, als man tatsächlich fährt, damit man nicht so schnell fährt. Und ich dachte, das ist ja brillant, das ist ja eine geniale Idee. Das ist ja eine absolut geniale Idee. Natürlich, als Autohersteller stellst du den Tacho so ein, dass er 5 kmh schneller ist, die Leute fahren per se 5 km schneller. Allerdings, glaube ich, ist es eines dieser Systeme, das komplett nach hinten losgeht, weil die Leute ja das irgendwann wissen und dann immer denken, ja, es ist ja eh ein bisschen drüber, und dann immer zu schnell fahren und schlechtestenfalls sogar schneller als fünf kmh zu schnell fahren. Und es ist genau dieses System, das nicht nach hinten losgeht. Man biegt sich auch die Welt zurecht. Also ich habe nämlich zum Beispiel, ich wurde mal geblitzt und habe auf dem Tacho geguckt und es war, was ich auf dem Tacho gesehen habe, war exakt die Geschwindigkeit, die ich in dem Brief bescheinigt bekommen habe, wo drin stand, du bist so und so viel zu schnell gefahren.
Es war exakt das Gleiche. Da habe ich gesehen, dass mein Tacho genau das Gleiche anzeigt. Und dann habe ich aber so ein kleines mobiles Navi immer in meinem Auto und das zeigt immer eine langsamere Geschwindigkeit an. Also ich sehe auf meinem Tacho und ich weiss, ich fahre genau diese Geschwindigkeit, aber mein Tacho zeigt statt 30 25 an und natürlich fahre ich dann, natürlich biege ich mir das so zurecht, dass ich immer nach dem Navi fahre, um selber schneller fahren zu können. Ja klar, natürlich. Das Navi ist ja mit Satelliten und so, die bewegen sich ja auch total. Ja genau, so red ich mir das dann ein. Das muss doch besser wissen, wie schnell ich fahre, als mein Tacho. Aber ich finde, also das ist so, ich möchte einen neuen Begriff einführen, und zwar Autotacho-Prinzip. Wie geil ist es, wenn man sich so einen Zettel, einfach so ein Papier ins Auto hängt, wo 30, so handgeschrieben, und am Ende 30 draufsteht. Da würde ich mich darauf verlassen wahrscheinlich. Absolut. Weil ich finde, das ist so das Autotacho-Prinzip und genauso das gleiche gilt für der Gedanke zählt. Weil gerade wenn man sagt, nur der Gedanke zählt, dann zählt es ja eigentlich genau nicht mehr. Weil der Gedanke, der zählt, ist ja genau der Gedanke, dass nicht nur der Gedanke zählt, sondern dass es eben, also zum Geschenk, wenn man jetzt jemandem was kauft, was der nicht will, so, dann sagt man immer, ja, der Gedanke zählt ja, aber der Gedanke ist ja nicht. Das ist einfach verinnerlicht, ist einfach nur eine Faulheit-Bescheinigung. Die Person hat es ja trotzdem der anderen Person gekauft, mit dem Willen, ihr etwas Schönes zu schenken.
Allerdings, wenn man jetzt wirklich nach der Gedanke zählt lebt, kann man ja irgendwas kaufen. Und dann würde man sich auch nicht mehr freuen, wenn man sagt, ja, der Gedanke zählt, ja, deswegen habe ich dir hier irgendwie ein Diener-Vierblätter, 180.000 gekauft. Dann sagt man ja auch, ja, das ist eigentlich nicht der seine Sache, weil eigentlich nicht der Gedanke zählt, sondern es muss ein echter
Gedanke sein.
Ich konnte dir folgen, aber ich weiß nicht, was ich dem hinzuzufügen soll.
Ist das jetzt eine tolle Erkenntnis?
Nein, ich meine nur, man sollte das nicht sagen, der Gedanke zählt, weil das führt
in einen Teufelskreis, der einfach irgendwann in Depression und Frustration endet, weil
die Leute sich dann denken, wenn du dir Weihnachtsgeschenke einkaufst und du weißt nicht, was du kaufen sollst, dann denkst du, ja, es zählt ja eh der Gedanke und den hab ich ja gerade.
Bist du denn jemand, der das ganze Jahr, also wir machen das Thema übrigens bewusst heute, weil ja bald Weihnachten ist. Genau, wenn wir heute schon anfangen, euch über Weihnachtsgeschenke Gedanken zu machen, habt ihr im Dezember keinen Stress und könnt mehr Podcast-Ufer hören. Bist du denn so jemand, der das ganze Jahr mit so einem Blog hinter Leuten herläuft und mitschreibt, wenn die mal verlauten lassen, oh, jetzt könnte ich aber Oropax gebrauchen?
Überhaupt! Bist du denn so jemand, der das ganze Jahr mit so einem Block hinter Leuten herläuft und mitschreibt, wenn die mal verlauten lassen, oh, jetzt könnte ich aber Oropax gebrauchen, jetzt könnte ich ja eine Antibabypille vertragen? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Du, sondern du. Oh, ich hätte Lust auf ein Eis. Genau, dann schreibt man sich das auf. Ne, überhaupt gar nicht. Ich bin der klassische fünf Tage vor Weihnachten verzweifelt irgendwas zusammengröselnd Typ. Ich brauche echt eine Kopfschmesserplitte gerade. Ah, dann gewitzt aufgeschrieben, nicht reagiert im echten Moment und dann fünf Monate später, hier, ich habe dir zwölf Packungen Kopfschmesserplatten geschenkt. Du sag mal, kannst du mir kurz fünf Euro leihen, bitte? Ist notiert, ist notiert. Oh, da wissen wir was, was dem Herr geschenkt werden will. Jo, mal gucken, was dir der Weihnachtsmann unter dem Baum liegt. Lalalala. Nee, also das funktioniert so gar nicht tatsächlich. Das ist eine geile Vorstellung. Also du bist ja nicht so jemand, der das macht, sondern du reagierst spontan oder du bist abgehetzt vor Weihnachten, kurz vor Weihnachten. Ich finde ja tatsächlich, das schönste Geschenk, das man jemanden machen kann, ist, sich Dinge zu wünschen zu Weihnachten. Das ist das schönste Geschenk, was man jemandem machen kann, ist, wenn er mir sagt, was er zu Weihnachten haben will. Weil das nimmt genau diesen Gedanken, nämlich aus meinem Kopf, was das Allererdrückendste zu Weihnachten ist. Und ich kann ihm einfach das schenken, was er will, und dann ist gut, dann hat sich das auch erledigt. Das ist, finde ich, das Allerschönste. Deswegen versuche ich, diese Kultur einzuführen, dass man es immer so sagt und dann auch einfach zu Weihnachten keinen Stress hat und sich aufs Wesentliche konzentrieren kann, nämlich Geschenke bekommen. Weißt du, was super wäre? Darum geht es ja, nicht um Geschenke schenken. Was wirklich super wäre, ich bin in diesem Start-up-Modus gerade, ich weiß nicht, ich habe so komische Gebieten. Guck mal, kennst du den Akinator, oder? Der halt mit ein paar Fragen, also du hast eine Person im Kopf und mit ein paar Fragen. Ja, aber manche Hörer ja vielleicht nicht. Ja, ich kenne es aber. Okay, kurz für die Hörer, das ist ein Hund, die Hörer sind mir egal, aber jedenfalls. Kreativbolzen, ey, wow. Hui, was ist das, ja gut, bring die Schärfe rein, dann erkläre ich das nochmal. Ja klar, ich bring die Schärfe rein. Du hast eine Person im Kopf und der stellt dir ein paar Fragen und kommt relativ schnell. Das ist wer bin ich mit einem Computer, der findet jeden. Okay, okay, okay, okay Man kann es auch ein bisschen raffig, der Gedanke zählt. Alles klar, wir haben eine halbe Stunde geredet, wir haben nur eine halbe Stunde, wir haben Zeit, wir haben die Zeit. Aber das wäre doch geil, wenn dir so ein Ding mit ein paar Fragen, du hast eine Person im Kopf, der dir was schenken will und dann fragt er zum Beispiel, wie alt ist die Person, du gibst es ein und irgendwann am Ende kommt das perfekte Geschenk raus. Das perf perfekte Geschenk. Ja, habe ich auch schon gemacht. Solche Seiten gibt es ja und ich habe das tatsächlich zu Weihnachten noch ein paar Mal probiert, aber da kommt halt nur Crap raus, da kommt nur Schwachsinn raus. Wie solche Seiten gibt es schon? Ja, so was soll ich schenken, .de oder so ein Crap. Was? Du bist nicht der Erste, der auf die Idee kommt. Allerdings habe ich mir tatsächlich überlegt und ich glaube, das werde ich ab jetzt auch so machen, und zwar überlegt man sich ja immer beim Geschenke schenken, was hat die andere Person noch nicht.
Und ich finde, das ist ein Gedankengang, der zu nichts führt.
Ein besserer Gedankengang wäre, was hat die Person bereits, allerdings, was könnte ich ihr noch besseres schenken?
Zum Beispiel so ganz normale Dinge einfach in Gut schenken, zum Beispiel einfach mal gute Bettwäsche schenken. Einfach mal, jeder hat Bettwäsche, aber einfach mal zu sagen, hey, einfach mal so super krasse Seidendesigner für 80 Euro Bettwäsche kaufen, da freut sich jeder drüber, weil du benutzt es ständig, Bettwäsche ist super gut oder mal richtig tolle Handtücher oder irgendwie eine richtig tolle Matratze oder was, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen im Bettmodus, aber einfach sowas mal. Handtücherbett, okay, alles klar, das kann man nicht ungefähr gut einordnen. Aber einfach, oder mal, ja gut, das ist ja vielleicht auch nicht so zu nahem Geschmack, aber das zum Beispiel, glaube ich, ist was, da freut man sich immer drüber. Aber du wirst, also ich wüsste jetzt zum Beispiel spontan, was man mir schenken könnte. Allein was ich in diesem Podcast schon alles erzählt habe, was ich für Fehlkäufe mir geleistet habe. Getrocknete Mangos und Geldbeutel. Was du mir schenken könntest alles. Du könntest mir ein Sparschwein schenken, damit ich mir den Briefumschlag nicht mehr. Pflanzen, nee. Pflanzen, die sich automatisch gießen, könnte man mir schenken. Man könnte mir ein neues Portemonnaie schenken, was sehr dünn ist, weil man trotzdem ein Bündsfach hat. Ja, du kannst mir ganz viele Dinge schenken. Erwarte ich jetzt auch übrigens von dir. Durch diese wöchentliche Routine, die wir uns hier angeeignet haben, erwarte ich auch von dir so eine gewisse Kreativität. Schenken wir uns schon was eigentlich? Oder mal richtig schöne Handtücher. Wann hast du eigentlich Geburtstag? Ist nicht so wichtig. Oder mal so richtig … Du hast nie Geburtstag, ne? Ich habe nie Geburtstag tatsächlich. Oder einfach mal richtig teures Salz. Ja, einfach sowas, was jeder hat, aber das einfach mal in richtig geil kaufen. Oder richtig teuren Pfeffer. Ich bin wahnsinnig kreativ gerade. Aber das meine ich. Nee, aber das ist tatsächlich irgendwas, was ich mir ... Oder ein Kissen. Jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, was ich mir auch vornehmen werde, für Leute, die man einfach nicht schenken kann, einfach mal gucken, was hat die Person schon und dafür einfach mal 300 Euro ausgeben, einfach mal drauf scheissen. Oder einfach mal sagen, hat die Person schon einen Teppich? Ja, fuck it, ich schenke ihr einen von den teuersten Teppich der Welt, was wird der schon kosten? Oder jetzt kommt die Premium-Idee, was immer geht, Wurststrauss. Sind wir nach vier Mal zu übergegangen, wir schenken jedem einen Wurststrauss. Jeder liebt Wurst. Ich kenne keinen, man spricht von Randgruppen, ich habe mal gehört, es gibt Leute, die das nicht mögen. Ich habe doch mal was gehört, ja. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein Gerücht und es wurde auch mittlerweile widerlegt, ist, jeder liebt Wurst und Wurststrauss ist der Hammer. Super kreativ, bis es irgendwann jeder macht, dann ist es nicht mehr so geil. Oder, was auch immer gut ankommt, sind selbst gemalte Bilder oder selbst gebastete Gegenstände. Jeder liebt, meine Freunde lieben meine selbst gemalten Bilder. Liebe ich, ja. Die Schauspielgruppe, in der ich bin, liebt meine selbst gemalten Bilder. Ja, oder zum Beispiel Schinken. Einfach mal Dinge, die man so ganz normal jeden Tag konsumiert, aber einfach mal richtig gut. Guckt mal in eurem Kaufhaus, was ist der teuerste Schinken, den ihr kaufen könnt? Und schenkt ihn einfach mal jemandem. Der freut sich, weil man denkt... Da kannst du aber übel, da kannst du übel reinfallen. Also bei Schinken ist ja die Frage, gekocht, roh. Ist es eher der Serrano-Typ oder der Parma-Typ? Ja, ja. Das ist ganz schön heavy. Ja, aber ich glaube, da würde jetzt niemand sagen, oh, ich bin eher der Parma-Schinken-Fan und das ist jetzt ein Serrano-Schinken, was soll das? Ich glaube, man ist dann tatsächlich auch zufrieden. Was wiederum gar nicht geht. Also wie gesagt, selbst gemalte Bilder gehen immer, Ruchtaus geht immer, Käse, Parmaschinken geht immer. Was nicht geht, sind Dinge, die man anziehen kann. Also die Chance, dass man die Größe richtig rät, ist relativ gering. Boot kommt auch meistens nicht gut an. Habe ich schon dreimal probiert, zwei drei Fälle nicht mehr. Anziehen ist nicht gut, weil da ist wieder Geschmack mit drin, modischer Geschmack. Und ich glaube, Geschenke, je kürzer Geschenke dauern, desto besser. Ich widerspreche mir gerade knallhart. Aber so einen Schinken, den hast du innerhalb von 20 Minuten gegessen, dann hat sich das auch erledigt. So, und dann ist egal, ob die Person so einen Schale oder so eine Jacke hingegen. Und wenn man in so einen Longtalk übergeht und das Thema ein bisschen länger dauert, als du erwartest, widersprichst du dir auch. Total, ja. Und dann fängst du an, aber die besten Argumente zu finden für das Gegenteil von dem, was du eben die ganze Zeit gesagt hast. Genau, ich sage, wofür habe ich noch nicht argumentiert? Das ist wie so ein Argumentationsrat und man nimmt sich jede Meinung mal raus und klappert die so ab, bis man alle durch hat. Wie so ein paar Karteikarten, die du zurechtgelegt hast und eben ein bisschen dabei die Karteikarten des anderen angeschaut. Bist du auf der Rückseite, ja, Moment mal, ich lese die Antworten gerade vor von Trouble Pestuit. Ist aber tatsächlich so, was ich möchte, ist, dass Menschen das, was sie sagen, mehr von sich trennen. Man hat ja immer so die Vorstellung, dass das, was man sagt und man selbst als Person eng zusammenhängen. Also Rassisten sind Leute, die rassistisches sagen. So, das, was du sagst, definiert dich. Und ich finde, davon sollte man sich einfach lösen. Man sollte Sprache oder generell Kommunikation eher sowas wie ein Freestyling, wie so ein kreatives Ausprobieren fassen, wo man einfach mal Sachen einfach mal drauf los sagt und dann kann man immer noch sagen, ja gut, das war jetzt Schwachsinn, was ich erzählt habe, aber man muss nicht immer dieses ich muss es jetzt genau treffen, ich muss es genau sophisticated alles. Du denkst ja auch in Sprache, also alle die Gedanken, ich würde eher sagen, es ist nicht das, was man sagt, sondern was man denkt, aber die Gedanken, die du hast, du denkst ja in Sprache, das heißt, wenn du dir Gedanken machst, wow, das Bett, das braucht wirklich mal ein neues Bettbezug und ich muss endlich mal wieder Handtücher da reinlegen ins Bett, dann denkst du ja in Sprachen, also du denkst in Deutsch, was du gerade da gedacht hast. Und wenn du, ja, aber wenn du manche Vokabeln, manche Wörter nicht kennst, kannst du diesen Gedanken auch gar nicht fassen so richtig. Das Ding ist, du musst, also Sprache, der Wortschatz, den der Mensch hat, auf den der Mensch zugreifen kann, definiert auch die Gedankenwelt und den Geistreichtum, den du hast. Also du bist immer nur so schlau, auch wenn du in einer neuen Sprache bist, fällt es mir oft auch, dass ich dumm bin. Ich bin zum Beispiel in Englisch nicht so zu Hause und kenne nicht so viele Wörter, deswegen kann ich Gedanken schlechter fassen und denke aber auch viel einfacher in dieser Sprache. Absolut. Das ist schon interessant. Ja, natürlich, aber ich finde es schon schade, dass Sprache so als etwas aufgefasst wird, was so sicher sein muss. Man wird darauf festgenagelt, Politiker werden darauf festgenagelt, sie haben das gesagt vor drei Jahren. Anwälte, auch speziell Anwälte, wenn du auch festgust. Was weiß ich denn, was ich letzte Woche gesagt habe und so, ja, du hast dir gerade widersprochen, ja, scheiß drauf, das ist ein Fluss, das ist ein Wandel, ich, ich, denk mir das Zeug doch gerade aus. Ja, aber wir wollen hier einen Mord aufklären. Wir wollen hier einen Mord aufklären. Ja, aber mir fällt gerade die Wörter nicht ein. Ja, aber Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie in der Kirche waren um acht Uhr. Ach Gott, was weiß ich denn, ist mir doch egal. Kirche, Messerladen, wo auch immer. Hey. Wo waren Sie als der Mordstadt fahrend? Im Messerladen? Die denken war schlecht. Und der Anwalt zieht die direkt zur Seite so.ht die direkt zur Seite. Das war nicht gut. Ich war im Galgenladen. Ich war auf einem mordsguten Konzert. Wenn man genau die Assoziationskette direkt vermerkt. Ja, unser Mann wurde erstochen. Ja, ich war im Messerladen. Der Mann wurde erschossen. Ja, ich war im Zirkus. Antigag, je nachdem. Ja, sehr gut. Man kann es ja mal probieren. Getränke sind tatsächlich auch sowas, wo man oft bei Geschenken sagt nein. Vor allem und Tiere. Tiere sollte man nur jemandem schenken, dem man, man kann mit Geschenken auch gut jemanden demütigen oder jemanden nerven. Klassiker, das Schlagzeug, man schenkt dem kleinen Menschen, dessen Eltern man nicht mag, Schlagzeug, damit er den Eltern auf den Sack geht, oder man schenkt dem einfach einen Wal, einen Walfisch. Stell dir das mal vor, so Benni, du fragst dich bestimmt, was du geschenkt bekommst zu Weihnachten, komm mal kurz ins Bad, was ist denn das in der Badewanne, ein Delfin. Ein toter Delfin, er hat die Reisen nicht überlebt, ah. Hängt dann so ein Delfin in der Badewanne und man füttert den halt dann ständig und der hat halt einfach ein scheiß Leben. Aber er ist halt Teil der Familie. Oder wenn man, natürlich der Klassiker, man will einen Tiger verschenken und dann kommt man mit in die Küche. Oh nein, man geht rein, spielunkt und sieht, dass die ganze Küche voller Blut ist. Okay, wir bleiben doch erstmal im Wohnzimmer. Ich glaube, ich glaube, Weihnachten auf der Arche Noah war echt lame, oder? Vor allem, wie viele Tierarten mussten eigentlich sterben, bis man die Raumaufteilung, die Tischverteilung vor allem, die Tischverteilung am Heiligabend zum Beispiel, war doch bestimmt eine riesen Diskussion. Wir können die Antilopen nicht zu den Löwen setzen, wir können die nicht zusammensetzen. Wo ich herkomme, ist man eine eine Gans zu Weihnachten. Von daher wie viel haben wir noch? Ganz schlecht. Gott sei Dank sitzt eine Gans im Festivalkomitee und hat ein Wörtchen mitzureden. Ja, oder vor allem, es gibt dann so die Futtergänse und halt die New World Gänse und die Futtergänse Leute, warum werden wir jetzt gegessen und die nicht sind das die New-World-Gänse? Ja, mein Gott, da gibt es bestimmt eine Menge Streit, weil die haben ja bestimmt auch Fleisch gegessen, oder? Wie war denn die Aufteilung zum Beispiel, die Aufgabenverteilung, also die Elefanten, nehme ich mal an, haben Dinge gemacht, haben nachgefilosiert vielleicht, Buchhaltung, Archiv und Philosophie. Wale haben sich um die Unterhaltung gekümmert, so ein Klassiker, Delfine waren wahrscheinlich so die Entertainer auf dem Schiff. Ja, wahrscheinlich, ja. Was haben Schwertfische gemacht? Lieber war so ein bisschen der Schreiner, irgendwie so ein bisschen der Handwerker, der hat sich so ein bisschen um das Schiff gekümmert. Ich habe gerade aus Versehen gefragt, was Schwertfische gemacht haben, bis mir aufgefallen ist. Gut, bei der Sinnflut werden die am wenigsten auf diesem Schiff sein, die können überall sein, aber nicht auf diesem Schiff. Ja, vor allem gerade bei Schwertfischen hat man eine gute Arbeitsverteilung. So, wir haben noch die Posten Verteidigung und Küchendienst. Ja, die Schwertfische. Leute, worauf habt ihr Bock? Worauf habt ihr Bock? Brauchen euch wirklich in der Küche? Genau, wir haben jetzt noch den Schreiner und den Schlagzeuger. Hammerhai, worauf hast du Bock? Man wollte die Biber unbedingt beschäftigen, damit sie nicht anfangen, das Schiff aufzuessen oder so. Ja genau, egal was passiert, beschäftigt die Biber, lenkt die irgendwie ab, Feuerwerkskomitee, habt ihr irgendwas parat? Ich hasse Feuerwerk, ey. Elch? Okay, gut, so ein bisschen hastig. Elch? Hast du gerade Elch gesagt statt Echt? Wie gut das wäre, wenn man so voll im Tierthema ist, Elch? Wer war eigentlich der erste Mensch, der Elch gesagt hat? Und damit laden wir unsere Rubrik ein. Wir wollen mal eine Rubrik machen, wir haben es schon mal angekündigt, der erste Mensch. Hier Trenner einfügen. Der erste Mensch. wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, dingilililililing, der erste Mensch. Oder haben wir auch so ein Musikbett jetzt, so ein bisschen so ein High-Energy Drum-and-Bass-Beat, so ein bisschen Fahrt reinnehmen? Genau, genau so eins haben wir. Natürlich Gamer-frei, deswegen wird es besonders nervig und es wird so ein bisschen midi-lastig. So Synthi-mäßig. Und es ist nur auf dem linken Kopfhörer, wir haben keine andere Version gefunden. Wollen wir den Bossa-Nuva-Beat vielleicht nehmen? Einfach den Bossa-Nuvaat. Nee, du kannst es darauf nicht summen, weil das klingt sonst nachher blöd. Ach so, da haben wir eine Kakophonie. Und da wären wir auch schon beim Thema, denn man überlegt sich ja Dinge, der Mensch hat unglaubliche Erfindungen hervorgebracht, sein Erfindergeist, keine Grenzen wurden ihm gesetzt in der Geschichte, allerdings bei jeder tollen Erfindung, die wir heute haben, muss es einmal einen Menschen gegeben haben, der das erste Mal die Idee hatte. Ja, oder das erste Mal irgendwas, ich würde es nicht so eng fassen. Ja, ich habe jetzt einen allgemeineren Anfangsversuch. Okay, alles klar, okay. Der erste Mensch, der eine Anmoderation gemacht hat, ja, wie muss der angeschaut worden sein, wo sie Leute gefragt haben, was ist das? Jeder von uns hat drei vorbereitet, Nummer drei von Stefan Tithjoddor. Der erste Mensch, der im Stadion angefangen hat zu singen.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also wer war der erste Mensch, der und die und meine Mannschaft vor, noch ein Tor. Es ist ja nur geil, es ist ja nur cool, Stadiongesenke, wenn alle singen und die mal krassen Stadionstimme. Ich glaube, früher war es so, da hat jeder sein eigenes Lied gesungen, bis er irgendwie gesagt hat, Leute, Leute, wir könnten halt einen viel krasseren Effekt haben, wenn alles selbe singen. Hey Jude, don't let me down. Also pass mal auf, wenn wir beide Hey Jude singen, das wäre wahrscheinlich viel... Das ganze Stadion gleichzeitig. Hey Jude, sing all the single ladies, all the single... Die Mannschaft denkt sich, wenn Leute sowas im Stadion singen, das wäre wahrscheinlich viel guter, wenn die Musik entstanden. Und das ganze Stadion plötzlich auf, gleichzeitig, Hey Jude singen, all the single ladies, all the single ladies. Die Mannschaft denkt sich, wenn Leute sowas im Stadion singen würden, all the single ladies, und die andere Tribüne, all the single ladies, all the single ladies. Oder so einen gregorianischen Chor oder so mal was ganz Neues, einfach um den Feind abzulenken. Aber das finde ich interessant, also wer hat, vor allem, er wird auch nicht mit der Stadionstimme gesungen haben, sondern mit so einer Und meine Mannschaft vor und los und schieß doch noch ein Tor. Wenn ich entscheiden könnte, würde ich sagen, die Bayern gewinnen. Ich finde euch ganz okay, also würde ich mir wünschen, wenn ihr jetzt das Ding da träffet, von dem ich nicht genau weiß, wie es heißt, weil der Sport erst zwei Tage alt ist. Pass den Ball, pass den Ball, I got this. Okay, meine Nummer drei, die erste Person, die jemals auf einem Pferd geritten ist. Habe ich genau überlegt. Habe ich original mir auch überlegt. Wirklich? Ja, aber habe ich nie aufgeschrieben. Aber ich finde tatsächlich, wenn man sich mal die Geschichte der menschlichen Transportmittel anschaut, gibt es eigentlich nur zwei große Stufen, von Laufen zu Pferd, einmal irgendwo im Frühjahr. Ja, von Pferd zu Auto. Altertum und Pferd zu Auto, aber ansonsten gibt es nichts. Ich glaube, in jeder anderen Technologie, Waffentechnologie, Unterhaltungstechnologie, gibt es wahnsinnig viele kleine Stufen, außer im Transport, nur Pferd, Motor, fertig, das war's. Moment, ganz kurz, der erste Mensch auf dem Auto, wo ist der, der hatte mit Sicherheit keinen TÜV? Also wo ist der zum TÜV, wo ist der Tanken gefahren? Ja, das stimmt. Superscheiße. Ja, vor allem, ich frage mich, das Auto wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht als ganzes Konglomerat entstanden sein, sondern da haben da Dinge gefehlt. So, alter Motor, richtig geile Idee, Gangschaltung, aber wäre halt schon cool, wenn man nicht nur geradeaus fahren könnte, so ein Ding. So, und dann, ah, die zweite Generation. Blinken. Blinken. Aber die erste Person, die auf dem Pferd geritten ist, hat sich wahrscheinlich richtig geil gefühlt. alles so wir müssen immer laufen bis dauer zu lang und dann so dieses dieses wesen da hinten könnte man nicht moment mal da da da da da und die erste wenn ein menschen so einer menschengruppe auf der menschengruppe zureitet und was machst du denn was machst du da genau die geg Genau, die Gegner greifen an auf Pferden und so What the fuck? Was ist denn gerade hier los? Das ist meistens die Reaktion bei der Erste Mensch unserer neuen Rubrik. Soll ich mal meine zweite? Es wäre so geil, wenn es davon so Reaction-Videos gibt auf YouTube. Guy sees Guy riding on a horse for the first time so What? What? Rastet komplett aus. Das wäre vor allem auch die Reaktion auf alles, auf alle der ersten Menschen wäre die Reaktion, what? Wie zum Beispiel auch? Der erste Mensch, der Haargel benutzt hat. Oder der, kann man einfacher machen, der angefangen hat, sich irgendwas in die Haare zu schmieren, aus Stylenistgründen. Also vor allem der erste Mensch, der seine Haare hochgegelt hat. Also mittlerweile akzeptiert man das ja. Also das klingt vielleicht nicht so spektakulär. Also der seine Haare modifiziert hat, genau. Ja, aber der erste Mensch, der wirklich sich Gedanken gemacht hat, wie er auf dem Kopf aussieht. Also jahrelang haben wir alles gewuchert. Es hat sich nie jemand rasiert. Es hat einfach gewuchert und alle hatten lange Haare und irgendwann hat einer plötzlich seine Haare hochgemacht. Was ist das denn? Wie haben die ersten Menschen darauf reagiert? Alles okay mit dir, wie geht's dir grad? Oder einfach ... Irgendwie siehst du anders aus, Gary, irgendwie. Ich weiß noch nicht was, es ist Jacke, oder? Hast du abgenommen oder so, irgendwie was ist anders. Ja. So einen kompletten Seitenscheite. Bei mir noch die erste, ich hab ein paar aufgeschrieben, ich kann mich nicht ganz entscheiden, aber ich benutze einfach mal die erste Person, die eine Metapher benutzt hat. Ist auch so ein Klassiker. Was war die allererste Metapher? So irgendwie, oh Leute, Kinder hier, Bianca ist schon wieder schwanger, da habe ich echt ein riesen Mammutproblem gerade. Was? Ich glaube, darauf war die Reaktion Applaus. Einfach nur geil. Ja genau, Applaus. Was machst du da, was soll das? So genau, wenn alle diese Sachen
gleichzeitig passieren. Es wird gleichzeitig geil. Ja genau, Applaus. Was machst du da? Was soll das? Genau, wenn alle diese Sachen gleichzeitig passieren.
Es wird gleichzeitig Popcorn erfunden, der Mensch reitet auf dem Pferd und er applaudiert.
Und es ist alles gleichzeitig, die Leute einfach platzen.
Alles gleichzeitig und einer ist klatschend auf dem Pferd gestorben einfach, weil er es nicht koordiniert bekommen hat.
Ich denke, die erste Person, die jemals eingeschlafen ist, dachte wahrscheinlich, sie stirbt.
Und die erste Person, die gestorben ist, dachte wahrscheinlich, sie schläft ein. Von daher eigentlich relativ traurig. Ich bin sehr stolz auf meinen Platz eins heute. Es ist wahrscheinlich so der most awkward moment of all times, der erste Mensch, der einem anderen Menschen begegnet ist, der eine andere Hautfarbe besitzt. Wie geil muss das sein? Finde ich auch gut, ja. Einfach so, die können auch nicht miteinander reden, vielleicht sprechen sie ein bisschen Sprachen, die laufen aufeinander zu, sind wahrscheinlich auch nackt, ich war damals, ich weiß nicht, wann das passiert ist zum ersten Mal, und sehen sich und gucken sich halt an, hey, ist alles okay mit dir? Vielleicht nicht die gesundeste Hautfarbe, alles cool? Ja, wahrscheinlich dachte sie, es wäre irgendwie angemalt. Super geil. Haben die sich als Menschen wahrgenommen oder haben die sich als andere Rasse wahrgenommen oder als Alien? Oder wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Hey, dieser Thomas, ey, das ist ein crazy Typ. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich es beschreiben soll, aber irgendwie... Aber wir sollten ihn kaufen und als Sklaven benutzen. Genau, das war sofort der erste Impuls.
Ich glaube, da hat der Mensch auch ein Instinkt.
Der Mensch hat ein Instinkt zu Rassismus, das liegt im Blut, da musst du ja gar nicht lange nachdenken.
Nee, aber ich glaube, daher kommt auch dieses Fremden, also ich glaube, das war der erste Moment, wo halt auch Rassismus entstehen konnte, so ein Fremdenhass.
Ich hasse ihn.
Vor allem, das ist auch der geilste Moment, wo man merkt, dass Fremdenhass folger Schwachsinn ist.
Da ist die exakt gleiche Person vor einem, die genau das gleiche Wahrscheinlichkeit macht, sie jagt einen Mammut mit einem Pfeil, dermaßen dämlich und unbeholfen, und sie ist genauso dämlich wie ich, hat aber eine andere Hautfarbe und einen längeren Penis. Ja. Das ist so. Aber warum sollte man darauf anders reagieren oder fremd oder feindlich reagieren? Das ist doch der Moment, wo einem klar wird, das ist Quatsch. Wir sind alle Erdenbürger, wir müssen uns alle lieb haben. Finde ich, das ist eine sehr schöne Aussage. Wäre ein schöner Schlusssatz eigentlich gewesen, aber wir haben noch zehn Minuten. Bei mir auf Platz eins, die Person, die das erste Mal ein Dialekt benutzt hat. Also, man weiß nicht, so ja, wann treffen wir uns denn? Ja, um neune. Was meinst du? Um neune. Du meinst um neun. Ja, klar, schon neun, aber halt neune. Meine Telefonnummer, ich schreibe nochmal meine Telefonnummer. Null, zwei. Ganz kurz, ganz nochmal. Was hast du da gerade gesagt? Zwo. Ja, eins, zwei, zwei. Ja, ja, natürlich schon. Ja, vor allem, man kann ja noch nicht mit dem Dialekt aufgewachsen sein, so, ja, natürlich meine ich zwei, aber wäre doch auch ganz cool, wenn man zwei sagen würde. Nein, warum denn? Oder ist so entstanden, man kommt abends nach Hause, hey Leute, ich komme mal von der Jagd, aber wie cool wäre es eigentlich, wenn wir alle zwei plötzlich sagen, statt zwei. Ja, genau. Alle, yay, das machen wir, und ich bin heute erst mal auf dem Pferd geritten. Ja, wahrscheinlich so eine Abgrenzung. Wir sagen jetzt nicht mehr neun, wir sagen neune, okay, cool, ihr könnt ja weiter bei eurer tollen neun bleiben, viel Spaß mit neun, uuuh. Wahrscheinlich ist es genauso entstanden, auch aus Fremdenhass. Ich glaube, jede menschliche Erfindung, jeder Geistesblitz kommt letztendlich aus Fremdenhass heraus. Ich glaube, wir können gar nicht anders als Hass. Vielleicht können wir diese Rubrik auch erweitern. Was war, bevor ein erster Mensch irgendwas gemacht hat? Wie hat man sich ohne das Wort Tschüss verabschiedet? Wahrscheinlich war Tschüss das erste Wort, wo man sich verabschiedet hat. Ein Wort zum Verabschieden hat. Aber was hat man vorher gemacht? Und es war einfach immer so fucking awkward, weil man nicht wusste, man Gespräche zu Ende sind. Wie komme ich jetzt aus diesem Gespräch raus? Genau, dass man sich sagt, wir brauchen irgendeine Flosine Floskel. Man läuft so langsam auseinander. Und man steht voneinander, man redet und plötzlich geht man einfach, ohne irgendwas zu erwarten, geht man einfach weg. Ja, ich glaube, solche Höflichkeitsfloskeln fallen einem ja oft nicht auf, aber ich glaube, wenn sie fehlen würden, hätte man ein wesentlich schlechteres Leben. Einfach weil alles so fucking awkward ist. Man weiß nicht, wann Dinge zu Ende sind, man weiß nicht, will der jetzt mit mir reden oder nicht, das ist einfach, glaube ich, richtig awkward. Das können wir das nächste Mal machen in der neuen Rubrik, ich einfach gedacht, das war auch noch nicht so alt und ich hatte kein Geschenk, dann habe ich einfach die Maus genommen und verpackt. Die Computermaus. Was? Ich habe die Computermaus genommen, verpackt und unter den Baum gelegt.
Und dann die Bescherung kam er näher und mein Vater packt etwas aus, was schon ihm gehört.
Was er nicht nur besitzt, sondern was auch exakt sein Gerät ist, was er sich gekauft hat vor einer Woche bei Amazon.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich möchte
dir die gerne schenken und du kriegst dann Geld von mir halt dafür jetzt.
Also das ist ja wirklich mal, wo man sich wirklich denkt, sag mal, will unser Sohn uns
eigentlich verarschen? Was soll das denn sein?
Hast du uns? Warum machst du das?
Aber ich finde ja tatsächlich geil, in der Entwicklung eines Kindes gibt es ja viele erste Male und viele Grenzen, die ein Kind überschreitet. Und eine ganz wichtige Grenze ist der Punkt, an dem man seinen Eltern nicht mehr einfach nur Scheiße schenken kann. Irgendwann ist der Moment gekommen, wo man alt genug ist, wo man nicht mehr einfach nur irgendwie die Shampoo-Flasche aus dem Bad nimmt, sie einpackt und unter den Baum legt und einfach sagt, ja hier, cool, viel Spaß. Kannst du ja nicht genau aus diesem Stadion wieder zurückgekehrt bin? Ich glaube schon, ja. Du hast den Kreis vollendet, wo man dann einfach irgendwann denkt, ich kann Mama einfach nicht mehr irgendwie so ein Papierzeitung, die ich zusammengeknüllt habe, was so ein bisschen aussieht wie ein Schaf, aber eigentlich auch nicht wirklich. Und das habe ich ihr jetzt geschenkt. Irgendwann geht es nicht mehr. Irgendwann muss man was wirkliches schenken. Ja, das war wirklich Geld ausgeben. Es war aber lustig, also es Lacher geführt. Ich weiß nicht, war es Lachen oder Weinen, manchmal liegt es sehr nah beieinander. Aber ich kann mich auch schlecht erinnern. Das sind so Konventionen, mit denen man mal brechen muss manchmal. Einfach mal sowas schenken, das ist vielleicht ganz lustig. Das ist ja grossartig, schenken, was er schon hat, was er sich selbst bekommt. Moment, du packst was aus und du besitzt dich schon. Und es ist auch genau dein Gerät. Ich fand auch dieses Foto auf Twitter so geil von diesem Jungen, der zu Weihnachten genau den Pullover geschenkt bekommen hat, den er schon anhatte, während er das Geschenk auspackt. Das ist auch ein geiles Spin. Das ist einfach so genial, einfach so Merry Christmas. Aber da gab es auch diesen geilen GIF von diesem kleinen Mädchen, was so eine fliegende Barbie-Puppe bekommen hat. Oh ja, so eine Feen, Feen-Barbie, ja. Und eine kleine Feen, unfassbar süss, und der Vater packt es aus und zeigt ihr, wie das geht. Und irgendwie war das so eine Vorrichtung, es fliegt hoch und man sieht nur, wie zum ersten Mal hochfliegt dieses kleine Ding. Und das kleine Mädchen strahlt. Und es fliegt genau in den Kamin rein, explodiert, es explodiert in den Kamin, in dem Feuer und es ist weg, es ist tot. Und schön bei solchen Gifs finde ich immer, dass kurz bevor das Gif aufhört, die Kamera noch so anfängt zu wackeln, so dieses wenn der Vater noch versucht, noch so hinzurennen, das ist der schönste Moment. Ich könnte dir erzählen, ich finde das auf Film. Genau, wo so spontane Panik, so oh fuck. Ja, oder 50 Millionen Klicks oder eine gesunde, aufwachsende, untraumatisierte Tochter. Das sind so die zwei Dinge. Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch eine Fähigkeit, die man als Vater lernen muss, wenn man seine Kinder filmt. Wann entscheidet man sich dazu, nicht mehr einzugreifen, sondern einfach Comedy die Regie übernehmen zu lassen. Einfach zu sagen, mal gucken, was passiert. Ich glaube, das ist ganz wichtig, den Punkt zu treffen. Da sind Menschen dann, natürlich hat die Kleinen dann wahrscheinlich danach geweint, aber da sind Menschen dann scheiße, da sind Menschen, Menschen sind da Dieven eigentlich.
Weil, guck mal, sie weint über etwas, was sie eigentlich noch gar nicht richtig besessen hat jemals.
Also sie vermisst etwas, von dem sie erst vor zwei Minuten erfahren hat, dass es überhaupt existiert.
Also eigentlich ganz geil.
Ja, das ist aber schon ein ziemlich derber Verlust tatsächlich.
Ja, eigentlich.
Also schlimmer, als wenn man was verdient, was man schon lange hat.
Nee. Erklär das mal bitte. Erklär das mal kurz. Naja, das weiß ich nicht. Naja, das war ein bisschen gefreestylet, man muss ja nicht immer alles Sinn ergeben, was man so sagt. Das war egal. Ich meine, der Gedanke zählt letztendlich. Da habe ich auch immer echt Angst, dass jemand vor unserem Podcast sitzt und zwischendurch immer auf Pause drückt und sich aufschreibt, was gerade falsch war an der Aussage. Und zu jeder Aussage so mindestens zehn Punkte einem einfallen, sofort die nicht stimmen. Genau, oder halt einfach dann aufhört, den Podcast zu hören und für immer und ewig von uns den Eindruck hat, als wären wir die absoluten Pornidioten. Wir korrigieren uns in die letzten zehn Minuten des Podcasts, korrigieren wir uns immer noch mal. Falls ihr die Podcast immer nach drei Viertel abgebrochen habt, Leute, hört euch mal die Sachen bis zu Ende an. Wir korrigieren die letzten zwanzig Minuten, korrigieren wir uns eigentlich nur noch. Wir klären alles wieder auf, alle Fehler. Ja, genau das machen wir, heute nicht. Ich würde jetzt gerne Feierabend machen an der Stelle, ich bin sehr aufgeregt, weil ich Farin Urlaub die Hand schütteln konnte und ich habe mir das noch nicht angeguckt, es ist glaube ich zu sehen sogar, würde ich nur mal sagen, einfach so. Ja, toll, großartig, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Stefan? Ich bin der glücklichste Mensch der Welt gerade. Lass mich doch mal ein bisschen Freude einfach sein. Ist okay, ist okay. Bist du glücklich oder bist du Herzaugen-Emoji glücklich? Nee, ich bin, ich kann das noch nicht richtig einordnen, deswegen bin ich der Herzaugen-Emoji ohne die Herzaugen, sondern mit diesen weit aufgerissenen Augen. Aber der bin ich eigentlich immer während des Podcasts. Okay, wunderbar. Nun gut, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, liebe Damen und Herren. Nächste Woche geht's weiter. Dann mit den Themen. Wollen wir mal jetzt einfach die Themen festlegen für nächste Woche? Nee, glaube ich, keine gute Idee. Toast vielleicht mal. Wir können auch mal über Toast reden. Auf jeden Fall, auf Facebook könnt ihr uns finden, das Podcast UFO, auf Twitter. Und es hat letztens eine Hörerin uns ein ganz tolles Foto geschickt, wie sie den Podcast gehört hat, wie sie sich da immer drauf vorbereitet. Und das fände ich ganz mal ganz geil, wenn ihr uns mal ein paar Bilder schicken könntet. Und es hat jemand eine ganz geile, es hat jemand eine total geile iTunes-Rezension geschrieben, die anfing mit Null Problemo. Null Problemo, was jetzt unser Catchphrase auch ist, das Podcast-Ufo, Null Problemo. Oder natürlich, die T-Shirts sind gerade im Druck, Podcast Ufo, keep it das Podcast Ufo.
Keep it das Podcast Ufo.
Es passt sehr. Florentin, vielen Dank.
Fand ich so schön folgend. Ja, ich wollte noch ganz kurz sagen,
schickt uns mal Fotos, wie ihr das Podcast Ufo hört. Hört ihr es beim Grillen,
hört ihr es beim Geschlechtsverkehr, egal was, schickt uns Fotos.
Hört ihr es, während ihr in anderen Podcasts
hört, weil ihr auswesend auf zwei Podcasts
gehört habt, aufgeklickert.
Linkes Ohr, rechtes Ohr.
Und ansonsten, ja, schöne Hoffnung, macht's gut.
Tschüssi. Wir heben ab.